you know the song guys fun fact when
olivia and i first started dating cowboy
bee pop was one of the very first things
she ever showed me wow yeah
yeah and i said that american adult swim
show was what you want to show me
that's right man it's one of our
crowning achievements of animation here
in america
beloved around the world so we don't
have a trailer this is uh you know you
gotta be hesitant to do it this stuff
i've heard some quotes of what the
creator has talked about we'll go into a
little bit more after that but they have
the opening title sequence which i can
only presume based off of the thumbnail
that it is uh setting out to honor the
original opening sequence but let's
check it out this is just for you guys i
think the show comes out in november
most likely we'll be covering it you let
us know down below if that is uh
something you'd like us to maybe do
[Music]
boom boom boom boom
he looks great
yeah
[ __ ]
okay it's definitely fair mm-hmm
[Laughter]
nice
oh
cool
all right i got a nipple chills right
now
it's really great
cool
oh snap
what's that guy's name
julian
[Music]
dude
that's up
i just want to watch that all day i i
don't remember like the the animated uh
opening sequence like shot for shot yeah
but i mean if you've seen it even a
couple times you know that's pretty
freaking accurate absolutely
absolutely yeah it captures the tone it
captures the spirit visually it looks on
par i mean you got to give credit where
credit's due and i think netflix is
really at least the very least doing a
great job at attempting to capture the
spirit of the original just alone in
this opening sequence yeah i mean jon
show spike looks pretty great
yeah
man i mean even from just these couple
little moments you get when he like pops
the chicken into his mouth you can
already feel like how much personality
is coming off
fae is uh definitely dressed uh more
clothes yes
it's the 21st century gotta woke this
thing up
one moment that really stands out to me
is when they're eating the reoccurring
things of these guys
that i vaguely remember i don't i don't
remember like i remember like beats
better of the show of plot points than i
do like specifics something definitely
worth revisiting before going into this
because this is a short show there's
only like 26 episodes or something like
that it's the one season yeah it's only
26 episodes to see them eating here it
looks like they're eating good food
they're always hungry and starving
there's such a reoccurring bit here and
it looks like jet especially who often
cooks for the team uh it looks like he's
enjoying some delicious high quality
food here somebody's making a bonsai
tree yeah this looks uh
yeah i think visually this is really
capturing it seeing it brought to life
is awesome
i i mean it goes without saying like of
course i'm a little bit concerned like
who would it be like as accurate of an
opening credit as this is and as much as
it plays on the nostalgia of cowboy
bebop which is one of the most absolute
beloved series of
all time and the opening credits being
one of the most popular anime opening
credits it's memorable
this is not showing us how they're
executing scenes this is not showing us
how they're executing tones of the
episodes it's not showing us really the
acting and i'm not saying that's going
to be bad i have no presumptions that
it's going to be bad uh i have concerns
though you know i've skepticism you have
are you telling me you're skeptical of
an anime adaptation from the studio that
brought us the well-loved and much
adored death note motion picture
when you put it like that
you're right
i'm enthusiastic
i haven't even seen them it's great and
everyone agrees on that you should watch
it and don't even watch the original
show especially not the first half just
watch the netflix movie yeah
i i
on the heels of that though i mean this
does look like they have maybe refined
their approach and probably want to very
much make up for
what i am sure netflix knows of the
public opinion of death note and
probably people's apprehensions coming
into this so i feel like releasing this
is almost a way of going no no no no
guys we're being faithful this is one of
the most beloved series of all time and
we're not going to screw this one up the
show is
not a sequel and it's not a hundred
percent a remake what they what they
said and this is the thing i'm not
getting from the clips here
but what one of the show runners said
was that they want to make it like an
expansion in a bit and a deeper like
exploration they don't want to do
anything that undoes or doesn't honor
the actual anime itself they're just
curious to see how they really flesh
that out because in a lot of people's
eyes the show's perfect you know like i
think there is room for expansion
especially because in the structure if
i'm remembering correctly they're like
20 to 30 minute episodes but it wasn't
always like hyper serialized or
constantly really diving into the
backstories of the characters like the
themes are always on display and you do
get to understand the past of all
because like so much of the show deals a
lot with uh
uh not being able to escape from your
past and the only way to move forward is
confronting your past that's like such a
big theme of it and so with that a lot
of the past is often mysterious
and uh i think there are other
characters where you you can't expand
the scenes out like this is ten episodes
if i'm not mistaken so it's going to be
hour-long episodes versus 26 short
episodes you know i don't know i i
actually i have no idea but when you're
telling me something you're going to
expand it yeah but yeah it sounds a
visual they captured it but it could
also be just a great recreation yeah
that's that's my point as much as i want
to be like oh this is going to work i'm
like
my cynicism
maybe it won't
yeah as great as joncho looks and as
great as they all look in their costumes
and and the makeup and all that it looks
like
i got my words but john cho is someone i
root for and as someone who is like
freaking 50 years old he looks great
it's amazing and he grew his hair out to
like have the actual yeah
and it's natural it's really great and
two i mean yeah it makes me wonder how
they're gonna approach the adaptation
and i i am
curious about and hoping that they can
nail something that is yeah adapting
certain aspects of the show adding its
own new spin on certain things because
at least as of these opening credits i
mean it looks like you've got at least a
couple of like bit characters from the
series uh we don't get an ed from what i
could catch here no but uh and the
producers have also been teasing like
fans are gonna be delighted so i almost
wonder if they have like a stunt casting
in mind for that or something yeah just
the the overall tone in aura it's like
this was i think a
a smart play for them because this is
obviously gonna get everybody hyped but
they don't have to put out you know the
story bits just yet so people's
apprehensions can be sort of on the back
burner i mean for a premier trailer it's
literally like at a 92 percent like
ratio which is pretty
is this is high it's good
but it's it's also kind of on the lower
end for a netflix premiere trailer yeah
i'm sure it's gonna be fun
i think it'll at least be pretty decent
great it's a matter of will it be great
will it be cool sure you know but you
got three main genres you're splicing
together here which are
noir
western
sci-fi and sci-fi so you got three main
ones that you have to splice your
together and uh which which are usually
represented in the characters like spike
is very western face femme fatale
and uh freaking jet is very film noir
and ed is slapstick comedy yeah that's
exactly right plus you know you got in
so you got you know your like fun animal
interaction airbud style yeah there you
go
all right guys well what do you think
about this are you excited for it are
you nervous are you worried leave your
thoughts down below be curious to hear
what you got to say let us know if you
want to react to it subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and we'll
catch you guys soon